Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
, continuing
the chapter of
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's observation.
We're going to skip forward a little bit
to the seventh narration in the chapter.
This narration
is on the authority of Aba Shad Ibuad.
Have we has anyone or have we heard
of this companion before?
I'm sure that when I tell you the
narration,
it's going to
ring a bell. The narration or at least
its meaning.
However, the companion is probably
lesser known.
He narrates that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said is a
very popular saying. Many people have
heard this narration before, have at
least
are at least acquainted with its
meaning.
He says,
[Silence]
We heard this before. You've heard this
before. Correct. Very famous statement.
However,
chain of narration wise, it's a weak
narration.
And this marks one of the first
narrations in
that has a weak chain of narration.
relied very heavily in his book
on the authentication
of
he also relied very heavily on
so these are two books that
is one of the main three books that
is really comprised of
less so but he does mention many
narrations from
and if you were to imagine
we said he passed away at how how old
was he when he passed away?
How old was he when he passed away?
[Arabic recitation]
39.
40 38 45
years old. He passed away at 45 years
old.
And that is very very young
especially for him because
and this is another point which makes
his narrations very or his his works
very incredible
meaning his achievements and what he was
able to achieve in such a short length
of time. He became
he started studying when he was 19
19 years old which is actually a very
old age to really start studying
usually. Usually most scholars will have
started before the age of 10. Now he did
memorize the Quran before he had
finished before he would had reached the
age of puberty. However, officially
starting to study Islam and fick and the
sciences of Islam etc. It was after the
age of 19 when he went for Hajj with his
father and then he moved from Noah which
is where he's from
to Dimash and started to study there.
And so because of that short time that
he lived,
, we see that he has to rely on the
opinions of the scholars that came
before him, especially on things such as
chains of narration, chains of
narrations. And for a person to go
through every chain of narration
and to authenticate it individually,
this takes this is a very egregious
process. It takes a long time to get to
a conclusion and sometimes
it could take days or weeks in
researching just one narration in its
chain. And so because of this especially
in compiling some of his earlier books
like
he relies very heavily on the
authentication of
and also on
meaning that Abu D of course we've heard
of Abi right and Abu D
mentioned something a little bit cryptic
in his introduction and that is anything
that I don't say that I don't criticize
that means that I view it as authentic
but that is not
an absolute rule and so because of
that he narrates
narrations from
and he relies on their authentication.
This narration is very wellnown and its
meaning is correct. 100% its meaning is
correct. But there's something that we
have to understand and that is that
not every good statement, not every
correct statement
is fit to be the words of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Just because a
statement is good, just because a
statement is true, just because a
statement rings true, even if the
statement itself seems to be prophetic
of something perhaps that will happen in
the future or something that doesn't
mean that it is fit to be the words of
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam. And
many if not most weak narrations
are confused as words of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam or not affirmed
as his words because of weak narrators.
A narrator who made a mistake. Right?
That's essentially what a weak narration
is. It's a narrator who made a mistake
or it's a narrator whom we can't be 100%
or 90% or 85% sure that these are the
words of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. And so because of that there
are many weak narrations which are weak
narrations but their meaning is correct
and the scholars might even cite them
and use them occasionally especially if
the narration itself has a meaning that
roots back to the Quran and Sunnah a
meaning that's already established in
the Quran and Sunnah and so they mention
this narration even though its chain of
nar narration may be weak have some
weakness in it but its meaning is
already found in the generalities of the
Quran and Sunnah. This narration has a
narrator in it by the name of Abu Bakrb
and Abu Bakrbiam
is a well-known narrator of hadith who
did not have the best most reliable
memory. But when we listen to the
narration, the narration is correct. Its
meaning is correct. Its meaning is found
in the Quran. All throughout the Quran,
its meaning is found all throughout the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam sunnah. So
the weakness is very very slight. The
weakness is very slight. And
alhamdulillah,
if we were to gather all the weak
narrations of
out of about 2,000, just shy of 2,000
narrations
is a little less than 70 or at most a
few narrations over 70. So approximately
70 narrations and that's a very small
amount. Alhamdulillah.
And second of all, there are no
narrations in
which are agreed upon to be weak.
There's no narrations in
which are agreed upon amongst the
scholarship of Islam to be weak.
Thirdly, there are no weak narrations in
that the meaning is incorrect because
sometimes there are weak narrations
where the chain of narration is weak and
the meaning is incorrect. Right?
However,
there are no narrations in which the
narration is inauthentic and its meaning
is incorrect. All of them have
some
some semblance of correct meaning.
And so this narration
which many people know
the wise, right? So a wise individual,
the intelligent,
right? An intelligent person, truly
wise, intelligent, clever, truly clever
is the one who for
[Silence]
them.
Right.
So here he's saying the intelligent is
the one who brings himself to account
justly.
He judges himself
correctly.
He doesn't give himself a bunch of
breaks. Doesn't
come up with a bunch of excuses
to justify his poor behavior.
The intelligent person is someone who
who judges himself accordingly.
And
does actions
for that which comes after death.
He puts things forth for himself. He
doesn't make his major actions and his
major efforts something that are
specific in particular to this world.
What he really works towards is what is
after death.
This all goes back to intelligence. Why?
Because the intelligent person what
separates us from animals in
intelligence.
One of the main differences between
human beings and animals with respect to
intelligence is that the human being is
able to imagine the future
and is able to tie consequences to the
present
even if they can't see those
consequences immediately. You look at an
animal, the only way you can really
teach an animal, even really smart
animals,
is to give them immediate punishment or
immediate reward. This is the only way
you can build proper behavior.
Many times if you punish an animal, it
doesn't even know why it's being
punished. It has no idea, does not
understand.
The human being has what is referred to
in the Quran as a
is able to look and conceive in the
future
of a consequence that may not occur
right now but will occur far into the
future. A human being is able to do
this. animals, they can't do this.
Animals cannot delay gratification
unless it's part of their nature. And
animals cannot
with withhold themselves
and fight against their instincts
because they have reached to a a
conclusion that this is bad for me
because of something that will be in the
future, not right now. Animals can't do
that. Their intelligence is too blunted.
And so the human being who behaves like
an animal,
this is un this is the unintelligent
person. an intelligent person. True
Kesa,
true intelligence and cleverness and
wisdom that a person is able to conceive
of this having an effect way later down
the line even past death.
And so
the prophet or and so in this narration,
the truly wise, the truly clever
intelligence, the intelligent one is one
who is able to bring himself to account
and
does things and works deeds for what is
coming after death. Because they have
deduced
that this cannot be the only thing that
we exist for. There has to be something
[Arabic recitation]